Sources tell
CNN that a
second Trump attorney has appear
before a federal grand jury
in the ongoing
special counsel
investigation of the former pres
handling of classified documents
Trump attorney Christina
Bob appeared
before the grand jury
in Washington recently,
according to sources
familiar with that,
who have talked to CNN about thi
She and another Trump attorney
have faced scrutiny since last y
when the FBI discovered
classified documents
at Trump's Mar
a Lago estate during a court
authorized search.
Let's talk about this
and other things
that are happening right now
in the political world
with CNN political commentator S
Cupp and Vanity Fair
special correspondent Molly Jong
Molly, how much of a problem are
mounting legal issues
for the Trump campaign?
I mean, I suppose one could argu
that Trump will see this as well
He's once again
playing the victim in all this.
He can be the victim
and he's a political martyr.
I suppose they
they might think of that one
to throw out there to the public
if this continues to go forward.
Well,
there are all
these different cases, right?
And there's the DOJ cases,
the documents, there's the Georg
Look,
I think he thinks he can
run out the clock and maybe he c
He is spending a lot of money on
And, you know,
I don't know,
different Republican entities
are also paying for lawyers.
So, I mean, look,
I think a lot of us, you know,
a lot of the little people,
the rioters, all were punished f
part in the January six insurrec
But no one sort of more senior h
found legally culpable.
I think there really is
you know, there's
definitely exposure there.
The question
is, can he run out the clock?
And I don't know the answer to t
S.E.,
are we just facing the prospect
of a possible
presidential campaign where
Trump is either facing indictmen
or under indictment?
I mean, is that just
something we may
just all live with together as
as as a as the American people
going through this next process?
As yeah.
And as unprecedented
and odd as that would be.
I actually think part of the rea
he is running
for president
is as a shield from some of this
Right.
If he's in the middle
of a political campaign.
He knows that makes the DOJ shy
a little bit from getting too ag
while someone's running for pres
He knows
that a bunch of different entiti
might treat this
a little differently
if he is a presidential candidat
So, I mean, there's so much cyni
going on in this.
And we as an American people and
just have to roll with it.
And I frankly think it's gross
and really unfair to ask us to t
to sit through this and
and say, well, forget about the
that really matter to your life.
Let's not deal with the fact
you have a presidential candidat
who's under multiple investigati
and is going to use that as a di
from all the other stuff.
And Mollie,
this week,
former South Carolina Governor
Nikki Haley is expected
to jump into the race.
Mike Pence has some events comin
Obviously, Trump has already ann
How do you think Nikki
Haley figures into all this You
she if you look at the latest po
she's not really polling very hi
What do you think?
I mean, a lot of people have sai
she's running for vice president
I kind of think that's a bit sex
I think
that, look,
I mean,
the Republican Party
has become very MAGA.
So it's hard for me
to imagine a non
MAGA candidate winning it.
And it seems like there's a dece
as Trump face off.
But who knows, maybe the two of
neutralize each other
and there's room for
a less extreme candidate.
I mean,
I think the thing about Nikki Ha
she's never stood up to Trump.
So it's hard to imagine
anti-Trump people or even just n
MAGA feeling that she is
somehow representative of them.
If anything, with all these Repu
who have sort of gone along with
they're kind of Trump enablers.
So I don't know how they
they paint themselves as differe
from Trump and see,
I mean, the other candidate
that we're all sort of waiting
to see what he does is Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis,
who has been really revving up t
with some of these proposals and
that the
controversial laws
that have been passed down in Fl
If he gets into this race.
Does it become,
as Molly was saying,
sort of a Trump versus DeSantis
And do you think he can take the
that these other candidates
took back in 2016.
Remember how just Trump one by o
just sort of
knocked them out of the field?
Yeah.
No Republican has beat Trump.
And, you know,
that should be a warning
to a bunch of them.
Nikki Haley, Ron DeSantis includ
We hope that maybe some of them
have learned some lessons
on how to take him on.
And Trump is certainly
in a weaker position
and the base is smaller,
but it's
also more condensed and rabid an
So it's really hard to penetrate
that is fully behind Donald Trum
If your name is and Donald Trump
so I mean, I wouldn't underestim
Nikki Haley.
She's really smart.
She's really well-liked
in South Carolina.
She'll have initial problems
with Tim Scott
if he also runs eating into her
base or voter base and surrogate
and the endorsements.
But an interesting poll shows th
Nikki Haley gets in
she actually eats into DeSantis
and therefore elevates Trump,
which I mean, that's a whole oth
kind of mind
trick that you have to think abo
when you're a Republican voter w
I vote
for for Nikki
knowing she might actually help
when really I prefer someone
like Nikki who's very different
from Trump.
I mean, there's a lot going on h
It's going to be a really intere
race to watch.
Absolutely. Okay.
We have got a lot of breaking ne
to follow this evening,
so we'll have to leave it there.
But S.E., Molly,
thanks so much for your time.
We appreciate it. Sure.